you're not gonna believe this but it
turns out that good old-fashioned
laziness is more deadly than obesity
that's right the University of Cambridge
did a study over the course of 12 years
where they talked to 300,000 Europeans
about their habits and we've got some of
the findings the greatest risk of an
early death was in those classed as
inactive and that was consistent in
normal weight overweight and obese
people simply walking for about 20
minutes a day can reduce the possibility
of an early death by sixteen to thirty
percent and we've got a couple more
findings for you a person runs a higher
risk of an early death by being
moderately thin and inactive whereas an
overweight or obese person who exercises
regularly can actually be more fit than
the same person who thinks that they are
already fit because of their physical
stature okay that was a lot of words now
we got this from riot dot or again we
have someone from riot org so rip into
this thing for me laziness verse obesity
I think this is problematic for me I
haven't worked out in like nine months i
have this false illusion of health
because i like can't gain weight to save
my life but um no I think that this is
it makes a lot of sense right and it's
the same sort of potentially
mind-blowing moment that you know
William Julius Wilson created in the 70s
where he was like actually the biggest
defining factor in your life outcome and
where you end up is your socio-economic
class and not your race and it's like
correlative versus causal and all that
and yeah it makes sense that like more
people who are fat tend to be inactive
also right but it's not the obesity that
is killing them it's the inactivity your
blood your your heart's not getting any
exercise you're dying from heart failure
earlier you're you know whatever getting
clogged and the blood is not flowing it
makes a lot of sense i think that that's
just sort of a maybe a good news to
anyone who is a little bit overweight
and who can't shed those pounds but who
is actually pretty active like you're
you're safe yeah I you know I was
thinking when I was reading this that
actually laziness is sometimes good
because I think we live in a world where
we just never stopped I think for me
like my inability to stop looking at my
phone doing all that like that's like my
brain needs some more laziness I know
that's not directly yeah related to this
but I think a little
laziness and shutting down and letting
your body kind of heal itself at all
that must be pretty good right there's
two types of people that haven't even
met each other like on earth basically
and those are the people that can't stop
it's like the can't stop won't stop
always busy very active trying to
achieve and then there's a lot of people
that really do nothing there's people
that report that they spend hours and
hours a day what watching television are
playing video games are doing any of
these kind of like my number and like
sort of kind of pleasure activities that
when you do nothing I think it's really
do gay people are gonna be pissed to you
well that's right I want to say that
they're working on their I think
coordination source I'm not calling them
lays you are judging it either way yeah
I don't necessarily know or won't
necessarily say it's better to be a go
go go go get her all the time perhaos
just chillin exactly so I'm not I'm not
judging you decide are saying it's
better I'm just saying that it's funny
when you say like isn't a little bit of
laziness good of course that would come
from somebody who's consistently busy
just wishes take a break meanwhile
there's probably a lot of people that
are no doing nothing and chilling that
it would benefit them a lot to go for
that 20-minute walk that it says right
there and it would make a lot of sense
also that people you know we is we're
very visually driven society so when you
see somebody who's thin you assume that
they're healthy when you see somebody
who's overweight you seen their
unhealthy obviously someone who's really
fat probably is not as healthy as they
should be but the study makes a lot of
sense i mean that's why they get the
term skinny fat to yeah you know it's
funny i mentioned this a couple eat too
but what was the movie i saw in her skin
with scarlett johansson i think did you
guys see it it was this random sci-fi
movie she did about three years ago and
in it she's a little more overweight and
by that I mean she's skinnier than 99
per the girls on earth but there's a lot
of scenes complete nudity 100% nudity
and you can see she she has some curves
looks like a real woman and I remember
watching think she actually looks
healthy and I never see that yummy I
personally look healthier when I'm a few
pounds overweight when I look five
pounds under I look way less healthy I
look gaunt and I am actually physically
less healthy and I think with women in
particular I know that wasn't the topic
here but women with fertility and with
health usually tend to actually read
healthier and tests when they have it
what we would consider an extra five to
ten pounds much more than the extra than
less five or ten pounds which is what
seems to be the value right and I when I
was watching movie I was thinking how
[ __ ] up it is actually that I'm
thinking that because maybe she looks
like two pounds overweight good see
the time that you know it may actually
be that she just didn't have a tan right
like for me I thought my way doesn't
right way back in Montana I look way
healthier I like way more muscular I
looked yeah yeah alright so get it
getting back to this thing though how
much of this do you think has to do
purely with what you were hitting on
which is television like I can't imagine
before television what people if you
were lazy now you just watch TV on a
Saturday you can watch TV for 10 hours a
day on any day you watch TV for 10 hours
a day but before TV did people just what
did they do that you know it's you try
to find a way to be lazier they stare TV
you probably the type of person I would
have sit and stared and wash the dirt I
guess the obese people before there were
television not as well that's what I
mean so it's two things but yeah so it's
sort of do which came first but I think
it was probably the TV yeah alright stop
watching TV don't stop watching YouTube
though and let us know what you think in
the comments right down below